in some sense all of finance is about
imagination because finance is about
saying what should something be worth
today based on what I think is going to
happen in the future nobody knows what's
going to happen in the future and so all
financial models are specifying in some
way an imagined future and then saying
if that future is true what should I pay
for something today
and so for example um if you're if
you're building an optional model you're
saying what will volatility be in the
future and given my estimate of
volatility in the future I can value an
option today if you're looking at CDOs
which sort of came a cropper in the
Bigham financial crisis essentially
human beings are saying what will
housing prices do in the future what
will defaults and loans be in defaults
and mortgages B and given my imagined
scenario for the future what should I
pay for something today that's sensitive
to that future behavior the big failures
I think or failures of imagination not
of mathematics the big mistakes are when
you don't think of something that does
come to fruition eventually when I was
in graduate school I went to see a movie
the night before my qualifying exams
called bedazzled with Peter Cook and
Dudley Moore it's about 40 years old but
I think it was remade a few years ago
Dudley Moore I think they're both dead
now Darla Moore and Peter Cook he was a
short-order cook and a Wimpy's in London
and he's in love with the waitress that
serves him Peter Cook plays the devil
and offers him seven chances to seduce
the waitress in exchange for his soul
and so he agrees and then he tries to
specify the circumstances under which he
will be with the waitress and so the
first time he says something like he'd
like to be in a fancy castle in
Oxfordshire and
with her and both of them in love with
each other and both of them wealthy and
the devil snaps his fingers and there
they are in this case on their around a
billiard table and they're in love with
each other but she's married to the
owner of the castle and he's just a
guest and she has scruples so she's not
willing to get involved with him and
every scenario he tries of these seven
scenarios and he gets wrong in the last
one he asks if they can both just be
somewhere quiet with nobody to interfere
with them and nobody talking and they
make them both of them nuns in a sort of
Trappist monastery and so his
imagination can never specify precisely
enough
the future that that he'd like to have
and I think that's sort of what goes
wrong with a lot of financial models you
can't really write down one short
description of all the things that
markets may do in the future